first of all let me start by saying I
saw the first two episodes I thought
they were so well done
how much going into this thing are you
sort of like even though the scripts are
so good are you sort of like you see
who's leading this cast
you see Apple and you're sort of like
yeah sign me up I'm good yeah good
little bit of that right but you also
want to have a character that has an
interesting arc you want to tell a
really fine fine story because there is
so much content out there I see then you
want people to actually find yours and
look at it and as you know because there
is so much content that's not guaranteed
just because it's got a big name on the
top of it
you really want to have a bunch of
collaborators in there telling a really
compelling story because no one person
can do it that's that's not what a good
story is about we've got a bunch of
people working together it makes it much
much better yeah I mean it's you know
the old tried saying it starts with
what's on the page and ends right and
having I got the the chance to work with
carrier and on Bates Motel prior to this
and you know she's she's a genius
yeah there's no every truly is so I knew
when she was attached I knew that you
know we're gonna work with something
really you know multi-dimensional with
with great characters with great arcs
and and with you know profound sort of
themes and you know and angles on the
themes and that's what Kerry does so
well she pours her soul into every one
of the roles and you and you see it on
the page nuanced conversations I mean if
you saw the first two episodes you would
be hard-pressed to hear one of the men
speaking in there who didn't have a
really good argument as to why this is
so unfair do you know what I mean
right see gross absolutely much better
but Mitch castor character was written
by a woman do you know what I mean I
mean we're looking at both sides of the
argument and we're being fair as we
possibly can I mean really a
conversation one of the things that I
set it downstairs and I'll say it again
yeah what I love is when there's not
like these exposition dumps right where
yes but right from the beginning of the
first episode you're meeting these
people and you're just jumping in the
world with no sort of ketchup yeah I
think that's right and I think that's
because
Carrie and the writers and the producers
and all the artisans and director of
photography said you guys just come on
let's go and it takes great confidence
in an audience for a writer and a
production team to say you're gonna know
what we're talking about just come on
with us and people just hop right on
forward from minute one oh and normally
that's how Carrie writes and that's how
everyone sort of sees it through the
prism of character and then you add to
that the fact that with Apple there was
no real time constraint which is
enormous ly helpful you know in in
broadcast television you're bound by 42
minutes and change you know so you a lot
of those character arcs are suffering
you know because in an effort just to
drive story here to Apple said
essentially well we don't really have a
definite you know time so the story that
had to be told was told in the time it
needed to be told and so that was that
was enormously helpful shows one of the
other things I think about the show
which I think will appeal to a lot of
people is that it just feels so timely
with one's going on like the timing of
this on November 1st is it's
unbelievable could you sort of talk
about that aspect of what's going on
talk about that a couple of times I also
understand that because it's sort of of
the moment sort of scandalous that it's
sort of interesting to bring in that
conversation but I don't think that that
serves the imagination the heart work
the authenticity of the writers and the
group the artists that got together to
tell this story
do you know sure I'm hoping that the
audience's that will watch it won't just
think about the stuff that they've heard
in the news but will start to really
scratch the surface go deeper on what
their own life experiences are like I
think there's so many stories that are
utterly relatable because they're just
ordinary folks trying to do a good job
so I hope that they'll go a little bit
further than just all this stuff that's
happening around the show go into the
morning show and really watch it